oh I didn't what I'm upset about the
fight
so people saw the fight I'm not upset I
mean I'm man I David I was just gone
dude I wanted you just came that nobody
could beat that man khabib it's not he's
not it's like fighting lava it's like
fighting like it's almost like khabib is
like one of those blankets you see on
the internet where it's like oh you need
this heavy this heavy blanket no you
can't sleep here here's this heavy
blanket for 140 dollars you can get this
30 pound blanket but I said I don't like
it that is a trap that is a trap dude
somebody right now people are like oh
yeah they've been they got the new
blanket and they've been asleep for a
month yeah the baby's been resting for
two weeks the baby can't get out the bed
because he's under a dang 30 pound
blanket and that's I just felt like I
don't know man let's let's take a couple
of calls about it some people came in
and you guys know that we're cheering
for Dustin the diamond Poirier and he's
that rare element I mean he should be on
the periodic table and and I think one
day he maybe let's get into a couple of
calls that came in on the hotline as
always the hotline is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three gang
gang what up Co I'm just sitting here
heartbroken I wonder how you're feeling
right now
Dustin Poirier just took that loss what
do you feeling there's no man from doubt
man and I tell you this we got so many
calls expressed and uh just people
sharing their moods during the fight and
what was going on what my thoughts
I mean the fight itself I thought look
first of all I don't know anything about
fighting ok I'm not gonna pretend like I
do I don't know you know I think Dustin
is a very neat person and I think he's
very dynamic as a human and so I want to
see him do well at whatever he's doing
you know like my investment personally
is in him as a human he happens to be a
fighter he's any any great fighter I
just think you know like khabib or
khabib or however is uh he's like kind
of like I'm to me it's not fight I think
it would be neat if they had to be on
their feet for half the round and they
could then the rest there's only a
certain amount of time they could be on
the ground now I'm not and uh and I told
Brendan Schaub that and he goes well
that's not the sport and and that you
may be right but for me as a viewer I'd
like to see a little bit cuz I want to
see both of them be able to do some of
the stuff that I really you know that I
like to watch them do I like to I like
to see the action at different levels so
you know that should kind of bum me out
cause kabhi be is [ __ ] boring the
[ __ ] is boring dude it's like watching
somebody lose their house to some lava
takes you know 19 minutes or whatever
and it's [ __ ] boring
so yeah go watch lava do get on the
internet they got a bunch of lava flows
dude I used to watch float man you could
you could be on a three-hour youtube of
a flow bruh
and it finally [ __ ] kills a sapling
outside of Kauai and you're like oh [ __ ]
man it was 3 hours of my life thankfully
I had a little bit of cocaine you feel
me boy that'll make the lava speed up a
little bit but that it was like yeah it
was like watching some I mean it just I
don't know and no disrespect that guy's
great it at what he does just to me it's
[ __ ] boring
to me is boring you know I'm gonna do
the UH you know I watch what I watch you
know and I like to consume things how I
likened to me the [ __ ] was boring and I
just you know I was just bummed man I
mean I was really bummed out and there's
people you know at the bar yelling [ __ ]
and and um and I watched it with Nick
and Jionni
you know the premature and the twink man
you know our crew we watched it together
as a team and and we were I mean the
first the venue looked like a like a
damn no air conditioning you're like
where are these guys in a tent out back
and I'm not saying that they just when I
was watching the on the on the fight
pass they got this Kouta MIT you can buy
and you get that you know special deal
on the internet and you can watch it and
it looked like they were in a damn FEMA
tent or something out back so but hey
you supposed to you know they can fight
wherever it's just the the the
livestream or whatever they had was
going was it was vit was very boring the
atmosphere seemed kind of mild and what
else but yeah I mean I was definitely
bummed I was bummed for I was bummed for
him you know I wanted him to be able to
win I know how much he really wanted to
win and it was very evident when you
watch his you know his interviews
afterwards and stuff and and let's get a
little bit we got this call I'll I'll
share a little bit more on my thoughts
we got this call that came in a
perspective from the arena here we go
hey feel what's going on this is ally
and you by hey Ally thank you for
calling man and uh you know and thank
you guys for hosting that event it
seemed like and even Dustin said it was
just an amazing event and if you watch
on on Dustin's story on his Instagram
story they have the dudes eatin gold
meat and they're doing all kind of crazy
stuff over there so really seeing his
experience over there is it's pretty
cool just to see a guy from just
small place in Louisiana to get to go in
that adventure that's a small victory
right there let's hear more Ali I just
thought I'd call in and give you some
perspective on how things went inside
the arena last night since you weren't
able to make it yeah it was hot in there
that's the first thing and there was
about a hundred thousand Russians in the
arena Wow
and dude if I see two Russians at a gas
station I'm driving off usually because
those guys dude they'll drink dude
they'll sit there to put they'll have
look they'll be mixing used they use
diesel as a mixer so you'll see a guy
with our orange juice and uh you know in
96 petrol you know their diesel enough
you'll see a guy at the Exxon [ __ ]
making a picture of mixed drinks those
are some there's some tough guys let's
hear more like so the boy Dustin was
definitely in some hostile territory and
they were amped up all night every fight
seemed like I had a Russian guy in it
just different sizes you know one guy's
like 300 pounds one guy like a hundred
pounds what they all look kind of the
same yeah I felt like they kept taking
one guy in the back and then pulling air
you know stuff and fat in him or pulling
air on him or putting muscle in him or
just like they were back there
Frankenstein you know they got a table
they got 19 things they got a beard
sideburns no beard you know more fat
more muscle here's some sternum boom
boom boom send him back out same guy
more and the crowd was getting amped up
there was about three more flights just
in our section so it was a crazy
environment and obviously he didn't get
the result he wanted but I just thought
it you know give you a perspective from
in there he definitely you know he
didn't win the fight but he definitely
won a lot of people over and he's got a
lot of respect from the people in the
crowd and I think people all over the
world now know who he is and what he
stands for and that's something that he
can take with him for the rest of his
life you know the mighty championship
belts come and go but that respect he
has and you know kind of putting
Louisiana on the map too he can hold his
head hard for that so anyway all right
thank y'all they really appreciate that
you know I love that on the ground that
just that lie
No thank you bruh that's really kind of
you to share what that experience was
like from there you know really you know
and and and and just the fact that yeah
you're right he can hold his head up
high that's something that yeah like I
was bummed that you know I was
definitely upset that he came in second
place I don't see how anybody beats
khabib it's kind of like when Michael
Jordan played you just but still it just
because you didn't beat Michael Jordan
doesn't mean you're not Dominique
Wilkins you know I mean Dustin is still
beat ever he's if it's anybody else if
it's any other time existence in the
universe you know he's he got half the
belt you know he got the belt when it
wasn't available to me he was he's he's
the pinnacle there's just there's this
other pinnacle that's floating off in
the distance that that's its own it's on
its own frequency and that is uh and
that's Kebede but I uh yeah I think
something about Dustin is I feel like he
- he pie doesn't even realize and he may
man this is I'm probably I don't from
being judgmental here or or hopeful I
feel like over his tenure as run you
know especially in the past year that
through through fighting and through UFC
he has shown who he is as a person and a
lot a lot of people even if they have a
great vehicle in their life that allows
them to achieve dreams or goals
aspirations rarely does also who they
are which is the bigger victory of them
being just a just uh you know a good
person of them fighting the good fight I
mean that's what his foundation is
called but yeah fighting the good fight
I think a lot of people realized oh I'm
a fan of
this guy because of who he is yes he's a
fighter but but he's I think he's like a
hero to a lot of people and I know it's
a kind of a wild word but yeah I mean I
guess he's definitely an inspiration and
so I think yeah it's like I just hope
that he sees I think that he kind of
transcended the sport a little bit in
the sense that he has gotten that people
see him as a as a communicator and as a
interpreter for good in the world and
that you know uh I don't know I just you
know some few athletes get to do that
few people in their in their genres of
entertainment or of competition get to
do that where you also see their heart
you see who they are and then that
becomes like I could see Dustin being a
mayor or a governor even like I think he
just has this you know he has this
relentless drive that is going to bring
him success in anything he does but I
just you know you know I don't know Here
I am pie like [ __ ] they sound like I
don't even know you know I just think
he's and he's such an inspiration to a
lot of people and yeah he'll have that
he had the belt you'll have the belt you
know he'll he might get different belts
but I think he's in this bigger
competition I think where people see oh
that guy you know a lot of fighters they
come and go but this guy can stay
forever if he wants to as a leader of
people and and I just hope he sees that
I hope he sees look I hope you I hope he
sees what we can all see that he's in
this bigger competition of of inspiring
people that and of kind of like of
competing on a higher level of a human
level
that I think that we all want to be in
the ring you know we all want to be in
that ring enough that makes sense but
anyhow man but thanks for that man
that's really nice you descend in that
perspective and just to have us to get
an idea of what it was like in there
yeah I can't imagine being in there
but I thought it was great man I was
fund and watch him get out there and
perform it was fun to watch him to me it
all seemed like a performance too but it
was very fun to see the excitement in
there and people just you know all the
crazy beards and everybody looking like
they got pubic hair on him everybody's
cheeks looked like a set of nuts up in
there and they got a damn you know
everybody's wrapped up in the turbans
what were the concessions like that's
what I would love to know that what the
concessions were like in there like at
the concession stand like do they have a
Pepsi do they have a dynamite what do
you know what are they what's for sale
yeah I think Dustin Poirier fights uh
you know when I was dealing I've said
this before I think but I couldn't you
know I never I was afraid to defend
myself nobody taught me how to defend
myself and my brother you know who is uh
I mean he's real he's really a light
house in my life now but but we didn't
have any you know we couldn't we didn't
have that we didn't have the ability to
defend ourselves we didn't even have the
confidence to defend to try and defend
ourselves you know and we grew up in and
place him is a little scary and um and
it made things tough but the thing that
gets me I think that I feel like Dustin
Poirier fought fights for people that
can't fight for themselves you know I
feel like he's part of this bigger fight
and that's the thing that I see about
him that um you know that I hope he that
he can read that he recognizes about
himself you know he's inspirational he
loves his family he's connected you know
to a higher power and uh and he's just
he's fighting the good fight you know
he's fighting the good fight and
and in today's environment especially
with athletes you know you see these
other guys egomaniacs and they don't
want to do this and they don't want to
do that and dustin takes they sent him
out there to the desert man where they
you know and he took it like a man who
said I'll go that's what that's you know
that's net that's the next part of my
life that's the next moment and I think
if he chooses to continue I think he'll
have many more opportunities but you
know and uh and I hope you will I'd love
to see him whooping couple more fellas
ass out there but I'm a fan for life man
I'm a fan look if that dude decided to
run for mayor if he decided to be hell
if he decided to do a cooking show or if
he just decided to start a damn pressure
washing business I'm in I'm in dude I
bought in you know I ain't got no
jewelry bruh but you know I'll let a
little bit of money on the diamond I'll
invest in a diamond right there